- Oh my gosh! You're a
vision, this is so beautiful.
- Oh thank you, this is
my meeting pigs outfit,
I knew there was gonna be
pigs here, so I was like,
"I have to pull out the best dress."
- I think they saw what you look like
and they were like, "No, she
looks too pretty for pigs"
"to be like sniffing on you."
- They were so adorable.
- They were so cute, they
do not like to be held.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, that's when the
velociraptor sound comes out
when you're held, yeah.
Have you ever met Joel? Have you ever met?
- We just did.
- [Kelly] You just did.
- I was in "Suicide Squad" though.
(audience laughs)
- No I was, but I would have been amazing.
So wait we were just
talking about time machine,
so if you could go past
future, like whatever,
if you could do whatever,
what would you do with a time machine?
- Oh I think I would go
back and meet my ancestors
and see where I came from.
- [Kelly] Really? That's cool.
- Yeah, my family and my
lineage of ancestors and people.
- [Kelly] See if
ancestry.com got it right?
- Exactly! 'Cause sometimes
it's a little iffy.
- I know I'm always
like, "How am I getting,"
"how's it changing? How's
my percentage going?"
I'm like, "Wait what?"
- Everyday I get an email like
you have new DNA relatives,
I'm like, "How is that even possible?"
- Like today I'm super Irish.
Yesterday I was like more English.
I'm like, yeah, I don't know.
- I wanna goo see it for myself.
- That's cool, I like that.
Well, your show sounds awesome.
So can you tell everybody a little bit
what it's about if they haven't seen it?
- "Euphoria".
- Yes, "Euphoria".
Yeah, "Euphoria" is an incredible show
that is depicting what young
people are going through
in this day and age, even though
some of the content matter
may be rough and it may be hard.
- Rough meaning like it's just real.
- It's just real, exactly,
it may be hard to watch
but I always sit in a space of gratitude
and being empathetic towards our show
because you have to realize
there are real people
going through these situations
and I might not be going through it,
but my peers and my friends
and my acquaintances.
- And you should enlighten it.
- Exactly, so that's why I'm so grateful
to be a part of "Euphoria",
season two is wild
if y'all thought season one was crazy,
I don't know what you're
gonna to do with season two.
(audience laughs)
But it's a really fun
show to be a part of,
I get to work with my big sister Z, so--
- She was just on here.
- I know, somebody told
me, yeah I love her.
- We caught her 'cause
they had to go on Zoom
and so we caught her, she
was in a real pretty dress
and then one of the cameras
caught her pants underneath.
(audience laughs)
It was like her workout
pants, it was awesome.(laughs)
- Yeah, she's an incredible human,
so I get to work with
some really great people
and be a part of a really cool show.
- What a cool life you have, oh my gosh!
So Drake is a producer of the
show, I did not know that.
So how involved is he? Is he involved?
- No, he's really involved,
we were doing table reads for season two
a couple of months back.
And of course, like
you're not expecting Drake
to be at your table read.
- You're expecting him to
be on tour, busy, yeah.
- Exactly, like performing somewhere
in his big old house in Canada.
And I pull up to the lot
and he's there with all
of his homies, it's him
and then his business
partner, future, the prince
and they literally sat through,
I think it was a three hour table read
'cause we went through
a couple of episodes
and he was so involved and so in tune
and you don't really
expect that from a person,
I know that he's a brilliant
businessman and creative,
but I mean he's Drake,
he doesn't really have to pay attention
in the table read and he did.
- [Kelly] I mean that's cool though, yeah.
- Yeah, but he did come from
acting, so it makes sense.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, he did, I didn't know
that, but in Canada he did,
I didn't know that either.
- Yeah, "Degrassi" is a very similar show.
(audience laughs)
Canadian show.
- I know, I didn't know,
that's when he told me that
and I was like, "Oh! I had no idea,"
I only knew him because of his music
but that's cool, all right.
I love that he didn't
just slap his name on it,
that he's involved with it, that's cool.
- Exactly, that's really cool.
- He doesn't interrupt and go
like, "You're doing it wrong."
(audience laughs)
- No, he's so in tune
and of course I was kind
of like looking at him
to see if he was actually paying attention
and turning his pages
and you could tell he was
feeling all the emotion,
I was like, "Okay Drake."
- That's so cool.
And it makes you feel good too
that he's really into your
project that he's doing,
that so cool.